you eventually end up as a CIA a friend
basically was like Hey you know you're
looking for work but it sounds like
maybe you didn't know that it was the
CIA what you would be doing like my
buddy called me and I was like no I
don't want to work at Blackwater why not
contractors in general had a reputation
back then they had the reputation of
being bloodthirsty do you ever get in a
situation where they were here like [ __ ]
they know that I'm here oh yeah how do
you know that they know well uh they'll
shoot at you okay all right where's just
[ __ ] complex the good guys can do bad
things the bad guys can do good things
is there one of the situation that's
like the most dangerous that you could
describe in some degree of detail yeah
one time I was in a safe house turns out
we did get compromised we had over 100
Taliban fighters closing unarmed
position bullets uh flying everywhere I
didn't think we were making it out of
that it was we're probably gonna die
let's destroy all the classified
information and hope for the best okay
all right guys bang bang I've got Sean
here with me uh I thought a great place
to start would be Navy Seals are known
for just incredible training programs
and process uh we produce some of the
best warfighters in the world but in
some ways the Navy SEAL methodology is
also like an apprenticeship model where
you spend time training you get through
kind of selection and all these but then
you go to a team and you're the new guy
and you very much uh learn from the
people who've been doing it longer talk
a little bit about that experience and
like do you learn more in the training
process or do you learn more on the team
kind of just doing it and being thrown
into the fire with people who are older
more experienced than you
that's it you learn a lot in training
but you you don't really learn how to
be a seal in training and so when you
show up to the team you hear all the
rumors and you know oh we're gonna get
the [ __ ] beat out of us or whatever and
from from actually for me personally
that did not happen right off the bat
but uh my when I showed up my platoon
had a different methodology where they
they actually had it really bad they
showed up and there was a lot of kind of
unnecessary hazing and knocking people
around and stuff and so they wanted to
do it different it was almost I don't
know passive aggressive is the right
word but when you when you get out of
Bud's training and you get out of sqt
and you show up to the team you think
you're on top of the world you got your
Trident and you think oh yeah I'm a seal
little do you know you know you're
you know about this much of what it
takes to go to combat uh with a silver
tune and so what though what when I
showed up my platoon they kind of waited
for that ego to develop and then they
shut it down real fast but but as far as
learning
um and I think they're a lot better
about it today learning is
when you show up to the team you got
kind of two types of two types of seals
when I was in you got the guys that are
just they're just going to be an [ __ ]
to you no matter what you know and if
you mess up then you're gonna hear about
it and they don't really correct you and
then you have the guys who are the
superstars and they'll tune you up and
then they'll take you to the side and
say look this is how we need things to
be done and this is a better way to do
it and this is a better way to integrate
into the team or a better way to clear
that room and and for some reason those
guys always wind up being the rock star
operators you know that that really know
their [ __ ] the guys that can put their
ego aside and and help help the fngs
yeah you know the business world has
become obsessed with the military in
general uh but I think seals in recent
years have been celebratized and kind of
plastered across the media and obviously
there's a number of stories of both uh
heroic actions but also just results uh
that have become quite popular and I
think the reason why so many people in
the business world are obsessed with
this is because there's the aspects of
leadership and teamwork and things that
run across all organizations but the
difference is in the military if
somebody screws up like it's literally
life or death right and so the stakes
are higher and and you need that
cohesiveness when you were operating in
the SEAL Teams and you're talking about
these kind of superstars it sounds like
there was like this knowledge transfer
where yes they would be [ __ ] they
would kind of hold you accountable but
they would still be willing to teach how
important was it that your peers were
also teaching versus if it had come top
down and it had been maybe officers or
people kind of back at uh um you know
some sort of headquarters unit or
something like that trying to tell you
what to do is it important that it was
like the peers rather than more maybe
more
um kind of the superiors or do you think
that it was just know if you got the
knowledge it would have had the same
impact
well that's a that's a great question
but it's not
100 relevant because the officers and
and the the upper Head Shed a lot of
times they don't have the skills that
the actual guys aren't running the team
are or or the ground guys you know so
let's like an officer most officers
don't go to sniper School most officers
don't go to communication School most
officers don't go to a breaching School
their whole focus is to learn how to
lead you know and so what they do is
they allow all the guys who are the
resident expert in their specific genre
to teach the new guys you know their
skill sets so they'll take a breacher a
breacher is a guy who is uh he blows
doors up he's a master of entry and so
they'll take the top breachers and
they'll run the new guys through you
know through a a basic breaching course
to get them you know kind of up to speed
in the snipers you know will run guys
who haven't been through sniper School
through a basic sniper course stalking
shot placement all that kind of stuff
same with com same with diving same with
everything and so when you get to a Seal
Team you have your head shut and they're
in charge but they're really good at
disseminating like look you need to go
and talk to Anthony who you know is the
best diver in the platoon and he's going
to score you away with your gear and all
that kind of stuff and then you need to
go talk to Sean you know the the
breacher and you need to go talk to this
guy the the assaulter and and so that's
kind of does that answer your question
it does and one of the things that
Amelia jumps to mind is uh there's a lot
of debate around specialization versus
kind of a generalist and people debate
this in terms of building their own
careers regardless of the industry
people debate this with their kids right
should you start them out super
specialized in maybe a sport versus
allow them to play a bunch of different
sports to figure out what they like the
seals seem to be unique in that you do
have a specialization but you have to be
kind of a master of many other genres or
skill sets as well because you need to
have that well-roundedness because on
the battlefield it's not like hey you
only get to do comps you don't have to
shoot today right is that kind of a fair
characterization it is however that
specialization can change so
teams go in Cycles so when I was in it
was a about a two-year cycle it's a year
and a half of training workups going to
schools getting specialized and stuff
and then it's a six month deployment so
in that two years your specialization in
in the beginning of that is when you can
do when you can go into a new
specialization so you have about six
months where you can go to sniper School
Bridger School calm School
Free Fall School in all kinds of schools
right well if you go to one of the main
ones which would be like one of the ones
that I listed then that's your field of
expertise for that two-year cycle or
until you're placed into if I go through
sniper school you know at the beginning
of that cycle
beginning of the next cycle I might say
hey look I want to I want to go to
breacher school and then for that cycle
you might be the lead breacher you know
and then it all depends on how many
cycles you're doing and what you want to
do a really good seal will develop all
of his skill sets and as you're going
through these different schools uh in
the last 20 years you pretty much knew
hey there's a high likelihood you're
going to go to war right I've talked to
a lot of people who were in the military
pre-911 and they were like yeah we went
to schools it was cool we kind of were
screwing around
um didn't really know what else to do
with my life but like the threat of war
was not nearly as uh obvious and people
would get deployed but did go to Kosovo
or somewhere where you know yes
technically you're forward but it's it's
somewhat peace time uh operations did
that change the way that seals trained
thought about going to different schools
uh or kind of the day-to-day operations
when not deployed knowing that uh you
know at a moment's notice you could be
deployed and kind of put forward into
some of the most ferocious battles that
we now are starting to learn about
I can only speak from my own experience
you know and when I by the time I got to
still training buds it was already post
911 so I saw a little bit of that
transition by the time I showed up to
the team what it definitely I could tell
that there was a transition and process
if that makes sense I could see the old
mindset especially of the the older
SEALS or the more seasoned seals at the
time
and then the guys that were coming back
from early deployments early on in the
war and when those meshed it was it was
it was an interesting time to be in
because you saw guys who had been in for
15 20 years you know who hadn't
been to a con to a real war zone and
then you got guys that are like me uh a
new guy coming back after one deployment
or two deployments and they have already
been to Iraq Afghanistan maybe Pakistan
maybe more and so what that did at the
beginning is it created a lot of uh it
created a lot of jealousy yeah you know
because
well I mean you can figure it out you
got a guy who just came in who went and
did the job that the guy that's been in
for 20 years has been trying to do and
so that created a lot of jealousy for a
long time and it took probably a good
five six years I'm estimating to kind of
to kind of switch that mindset because
the old mindset was was and it still is
to this some extent was work hard play
hard and we work really hard and we play
even harder and that mindset kind of
started to switch you know especially
when he started seeing
um more and more guys getting killed out
there it becomes you know it brings a
realness to the to the entire Community
when that kind of stuff starts happening
yeah you know so so so the training
environment did change the focus would
be it went from let's hurry up and get
this [ __ ] done so we can go to the bar
too
let's not hurry up and get this [ __ ]
done let's get this [ __ ] right because
we're going to be doing this in two
months overseas yeah wait um I was
employed to Iraq uh for about a year and
uh in the big army there was two things
that I think surprised me in that
experience uh among many but two that
really stuck out the first was uh
everyone has this big build up to going
to war and now the big Army's going to
do very different types of operations
then uh the seals were uh but once you
kind of see it and you feel it and
you're in it
you're not exactly looking for a fight
every day right there was this element
of like okay cool like this shit's real
um and uh if we have to we'll fight but
uh it's not like we want to go and pick
fights uh just for the hell of it
because this is real right so I think
that was one and then two was as kind of
a a second component of that
um I happen to be in a platoon where uh
the very first engagement that we were
in uh the platoon leader was not there
and so everyone is getting Combat Action
Badges and kind of all these like I
think in the military you don't really
give a [ __ ] about but uh from the
outside they seem important
and so through the rest of the
deployment uh the platoon leaders seem
to make decisions that I'm not going to
say put people at risk intentionally but
definitely felt like hey he wouldn't be
upset if uh he was able to be in an
environment where he could get some of
these Awards and things like that
and so like maybe that was a one-off
case and it was just like human dynamics
but maybe not and so like how did the
seals think about this is it something
where most of the people while deployed
were like let's go get in firefights
every night and like you know I live for
this or was it more of like let's go do
our job and if we have to do that you
know we're prepared to do it but it's
not necessarily something we're seeking
out like what was kind of the maybe like
the psyche of the seals going on these
missions
for me and I would say probably 90
percent of the SEAL Teams it's let's go
get in a gunfight okay let's go let's go
do what we came here to do let's let's
we have all this training you know it's
it buds is six months usually it takes
guys a year to get through then you go
to jump school then you'd go to sqt now
I think the guys are going to some more
schools then you show up to your team
and you do a year and a half work up and
then you finally deploy so add all that
time up and then you finally get a
chance it's like
it's like uh MLB players showing up on
the on the on the field for the first
time it's like [ __ ] here we are yeah I
need it I need that bats yeah and put me
in coach and uh now guys that have been
around longer guys that have seen [ __ ]
guys that have that experience they have
a different mindset and that that is
another thing at the very beginning
um I was I was war hungry I really
wanted to kick some ass we had a lot of
deaths like
um we went in to Afghanistan right after
Red Wings happened that was the biggest
loss in the steel teams at the time
and we weren't doing a whole lot and it
was it was extremely frustrating for me
and for those that don't know Red Wings
was the operation Marcus Luttrell Lone
Survivor yeah um and I think ended up
being about 20 Navy Seals were uh were
killed during that three or four day
period And so you went in right after
yep and it was very risk adverse so we
had all these targets that we could have
gone and hit
but we weren't doing it and it created
this it it it
it really demoralized
um the platoon and
so does that answer it yeah you know we
really wanted we wanted to fight and so
it almost feels like when you're talking
about this demoralization uh you know
the targets are there you have the Intel
we know where they are we have the skill
set to go and and capture them kill them
do whatever is asked of us uh but it's
frustration that you're not getting the
green light to go do it you're kind of
sitting there without being able to use
the skill set let me yeah let me try to
paint this a little clearer for you so I
want to first of our second deployment
I'm sorry to Afghanistan we show up
first thing we do is an Intel brief in
that Intel brief is video footage of the
guys that went down on the helos that
went to
um qrf quick reactionary Force to the
guys on the ground and the sniper hide
Marcus axelson uh Dietz one of the first
things I saw
was a fighter a foreign fighter
holding up Danny dietz's ID trying to
figure out how to turn his night vision
on how to turn his laser on they're
ripping his clothes off and you could
see the fresh tattoo that was just
tattooed on Danny's ribs and
then we don't do anything you know and
and
the only question you're in your head is
why the [ __ ] aren't we doing anything
yeah who is that guy yeah and and then
you see him collecting all the other
rifles and going through the Helo crash
and and getting everything they can just
Scavenging off of our guys dead bodies
and so that demoralized us
um guys that hadn't been out yet
let's fast forward then we go to Iraq
and we're doing a just a lot of sniper
stuff a lot of we killed a lot of bad
guys that were trying to do harm
especially to infantry army they were
running convoys and it was just up after
drop of taking care of guys that were
play some roadside bombs well
then it started once you get it you know
and you get the taste then you start you
start understanding you know hey maybe
this isn't worth going out for you know
that we're not yeah there's a bunch of
[ __ ] over here but maybe we're
waiting for the big one you know and if
we go take care of all these [ __ ]
then the big guy's not going to come out
and so you learn to develop patience and
and you start to begin to understand you
know why things maybe don't move as fast
as as you want them to it it's uh
you can take that learning and apply it
across various Industries and
organizations like the young person who
shows up and it's like let's just go
build everything right in business and
then somebody says well hold on there's
resources there's budget there's
strategy there's other components that
you may or may not see
um when did you realize that you were
maybe gaining the experience or the
patience or some of the discipline that
the older guys had was it just reps so
literally just being on combat uh
deployments and and going on these
operations and eventually you just pick
it up did somebody like sit you down and
say hey here's why this is the way it is
and so you know once you have that
knowledge then you look at it
differently what changed uh you know I'm
kind of a slow learner so uh I actually
left the SEAL Teams and I didn't I
didn't really pick up that bigger
picture uh until I got into CIA and then
I started to realize hey there is a lot
bigger of a picture here than Sean being
able to go out and kick some ass every
night and uh and and it was probably a
good four or five years into my agency
career uh that I finally started picking
that up and the only reason I was able
to pick that up is because the agency
has their hands at so many different
things you start to build the bigger
picture yourself and your own head and
it's okay I see how all this [ __ ] is all
connected throughout the entire battle
space I see how how we're utilizing the
steel teams and how we're utilizing the
Green Berets and Delta and Team Six and
and and assets that you're running and
and and all these things you know and
and
and that's when you start to understand
okay
patient we we got to be patient because
we want to get number one we don't want
to get
you know the
minions yeah I mean it's very similar if
you've ever talked to like the DEA or uh
police officers right like they'll go do
street drug buys because they want to
figure out who this person is they
picked them up and say hey where do you
get your drugs from and they kind of
work their way up the organization and
eventually they try to get the leader
right yeah and we saw this you can go
look in the Trice area with the mafia
and kind of how they pinned those guys
military is very similar
um and I think what was fascinating to
me uh was we weren't being given
operations to go anywhere near big guys
or anything like that
um but there was names that were known
there was you know kind of almost
mythical figures to some degree right as
to oh we don't go over here because a b
or c reason that's so and so's you know
kind of domain and you're like well if
we know that dude's name yeah right
you're telling me that the the might and
power of the United States military
can't figure out where the [ __ ] that guy
is right uh and so it's like very weird
to some degree
um
but I do think that your point about
like once you got exposed to more you
you learned
um
when you left the seals you didn't
expect to go to the CIA you went and if
I remember correctly uh wanted to go
into like more business and kind of the
investment world yeah I read uh I read
Donald Trump's book uh The Apprentice
was it the no how to get rich it was how
to get rich I picked it up and actually
I picked it up in Cuba
at Guantanamo Bay and I read the whole
thing in like two days and I was like
[ __ ] hey man I'm gonna go get bread
and
they're like well how are you going to
do that and I was like I'm gonna sell my
[ __ ] condo and I'm gonna use that
money to start flipping houses and I'm
gonna become a real estate agent and
then that turned into an a whole
disaster how how long did you last doing
that oh man probably I sold one house to
my ex-girlfriend's mother for about a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars
success yeah and uh and so pretty a very
small commission and uh
I I realized a lot of things very fast
I'm horrible at dealing with people
especially coming but I mean right out
of Afghanistan or right out of Iraq and
to being a realtor I have no patience I
mean I would ride around
and print off this is what back in 2007
2006-ish I would print off like 50 pages
of MapQuest because I was too broke to
buy Tom Tom do you know what a TomTom is
yeah yeah and I would hand it to the
client and then I would get pissed off
because I don't know how to read a map
and uh and uh so anyways I just realized
I was like you know this isn't that this
is a this is not my skill set yeah
dealing with people selling this isn't
my skill set and so so I went into a
fire academy got it and um you
eventually end up at the CIA uh I think
I've heard you talk previously that a
friend basically was like Hey you know
you're looking for work send me a resume
and and I'll uh I'll see what I can do
but it sounds like maybe you didn't know
that it was the CIA what you would be
doing like there's almost like kind of a
curtain and until you're behind the
curtain you don't really know what's
going on is that yeah they don't really
tell you okay and um
so the way it was was I I left being a
realtor obviously and I was in the fire
academy
so they told me they were like look it's
going to be two years at least before
you even think about getting in plus you
have all the family ties within the fire
service as well got it you know and so
they need to entertain all of that and
you know where I'm going and um so
you know I'm an adult at this point
obviously I have bills to pay and I'm
like well this [ __ ] this isn't gonna
work I don't have two years to wait you
know for a for a firefighter salary
just so happened my buddy called me and
um he was hey
I'm working for Blackwater at the time
and I was like no I don't want to do I
don't want to work at Blackwater why not
well it Blackwater had contractors in
general had a reputation back then and
uh
some of that reputation is true a lot of
the Blackwater stuff wasn't true that
was other companies that were doing
things they shouldn't have done saying
that they were black water when they
weren't anyways
um
long story short the Contracting
requirements I didn't realize there were
different sections so if you look at
Black Water black water is an umbrella
company but they also they have state
department contract they have the CIA
contract they have all kinds of
contracts maybe they have the NSA
contract maybe they have the DEA
contract that there's a ton of
contracts there's a mail contract to get
mail and uh delivered and I didn't
realize that so then they take all the
resumes that they get and they put
different qualified guys into different
buckets just so happens most the guys
coming from Special Operations get put
into the CIA bucket but they can't know
that anyways
I didn't think I was going to be working
with the type of people who I was used
to working with in the steel teams and I
didn't
I wasn't in in contractors at the time
where they had the reputation of being
bloodthirsty and um and and for those
that don't have the context one of the
things that uh ends up being
I think a challenge for the contractors
especially at that time uh is if you're
bloodthirsty but you're not actually
with the support of the military as we
saw a couple of times you're kind of out
on an island on your own it could almost
be more dangerous than if you had the
full you know support and Firepower or
the you know the military where you
could call qrf or you could call some of
these organizations uh you may not have
the best equipment like there was a lot
of things especially early on that
changed over time but depending on when
you were looking at it uh also it could
have been more dangerous than even being
a seal yeah definitely
um what what you had was you because the
contracts were so wide right and I
didn't realize this when I was in the
teams co-located with these guys uh you
know in Iraq and Afghanistan is I mean I
would
be in the chow line or something and I'd
talk to somebody like oh how did you get
to work here how did you get into
Contracting oh I was a Bank of America
security guard last week and I'm like
really you're
and now you're here you know and uh you
are not gonna have my back I don't think
I want to be a contractor when I leave
this gig and uh well anyways my friend
had told me he's like look it's not like
what you're thinking he's like it's not
what we saw overseas there's a bigger
picture here and he's like everybody on
this side of the house is like us
or better than us I think you might want
to give me your resume it pays extremely
well and it's a great gig to be on and
um so I said all right here it is I mean
I had an idea I was like all right it's
got to be a three-letter agency contract
or at least attached to them
and yeah so that's so I gave my resume I
didn't hear anything the first the first
correspondence I got was we need a full
body shot of you to make sure I'm not a
fat ass I didn't know that at the time
no way yeah and and I was like naked or
close no no no no
[Laughter]
full frontal with uh government was
running only fans before I thought this
was just a military concept but
um but yeah so I was like all right well
that's kind of weird so I sent it in and
and then I later found out hey we we get
a lot of a lot of guys let themselves go
when they get out and we don't want that
and so that's what that was it's amazing
people think it's so sophisticated but
it's like yeah it's just that as a
picture right like we're gonna get like
uh 80 of people filtered out that are
just fat yeah right and you can't be fat
in this job whether people like that or
not like you gotta be able to be
physically fit to do the job yep so and
they've already done all the other
vetting you know or not most of it
they've asked around they've got
opinions your name might be on a wall
that but it's a really small community
so they they already kind of know at
least a little bit about who you are as
an operator before before you have to
give the full frontal you know and uh
and then I didn't hear anything for a
long time again after that
and I filled out some paperwork for a
new security clearance and then I mean I
thought it was just done and then I got
I got up you know hey we need you here
on this date this is what you're
supposed to say like is is it your
friend is it like uh somebody's like hey
I work for the CIA I need you to come
here no because this was Black Water you
know I went to work for Black Water they
were basically the the what would you
call it subcontractor the agency's like
I need this many guys black Waters like
we'll find them they work for us and
we'll give them to you yep you know and
there are only four allotted for the the
agency contract which is called uh
special programs at the time or
something like that and so it was the
email and
it just came from a regular Gmail
account you know it wasn't like it
wasn't like Anthony at cia.gov hey show
up here or Eric Prince at blackwater.com
it was
gmail.com you know and it's like who the
hell is Joel all right well you know
there's your plane tickets we'll see you
here and uh and that's that's that's
pretty much how that it's kind of how
the military works right uh obviously
once you get into the Contracting world
and some of the agencies
um I think people would like to think
they're more sophisticated but in the
military people basically like okay uh
here's your clothes here's your
equipment and uh get on this plane we're
gonna take you somewhere and then you're
gonna do what we tell you to do and then
like you're gonna come back okay
so like uh there's some I guess
familiarity with that when you get there
is it like academic exercises because is
it like a tryout or is it basically okay
it's a it's a truck they're not there to
teach you they're there to vet you so
it's it's a tryout a month long try out
and so you show up and the first thing
they do is run you through
um a physical test you know just run
push-ups pull-ups sit-ups you know
I think that's I think that uh body drag
drag a 180 pound dummy so many so many
yards
um did you find it difficult or it was
like a pretty basic I mean it's pretty
basic you know again it's just can this
guy move as he let himself go is he
injured you know [ __ ] like that it's I
mean it'll get your breathing it'll get
a sweat going but it's nothing too
excruciating and uh which I actually
have to be honest with you a lot of guys
don't make it through that uh which is
sad but like I said a lot of guys let
themselves go so then after that you
start getting into a shooting package
and
um you run that shooting package you
just run drills drills drills drills
and they don't tell you
at least on this one they didn't tell
you times they don't tell you they tell
you how many shots and where to line up
and do it as best and as fast as you can
and that's it so it's like [ __ ] I don't
you know no slap on the back no good job
no no nothing no well I mean like how
fast do I need to be you know and you
know because you shoot sounds like you
should so
I mean you know the wheels fall off at a
certain level there of speed and so you
just do the best you can and guys that's
really where guys start disappearing
there's two calls that I can't get into
there's a there's a whole series of
pistol calls there's a whole series of
rifle calls there's two one pistol
called one rifle call in particular
they get
probably 75 or more of the guys
um they don't make it yeah and is it a
difficulty of like what they're being
asked to do or is it the unknown and so
guys may not try as hard or go as fast
or or they like almost succumb to the
uncertainty more so than the actual uh
skill they're being asked to uh uh kind
of display I mean it's all of it it's a
difficult call and uh you're coming
you're coming from concealed and
shooting a certain amount of rounds in a
very
show a few amount of seconds and then
um the rifle one is actually a two
minute long qualification but you only
fire I think eight rounds okay and a lot
of moving around and stuff but so you're
now like I think the best way to
describe is people listening or watching
is like uh this has now moved from like
novice hey can you shoot two uh are you
an elite operator yes who we can put in
certain environments and like you've got
a higher probability of succeeding than
most yes we we have an expectation and
you're going to meet the expectation or
you're not but go just rewind it a
little bit so when you do that you know
you're shooting for a job that's going
to pay you more money than you've ever
been paid in your entire life you know
so there's that then there's
you know you're already at an elite
level and everybody hates to fail you
know especially in front of their peers
especially when it's you know Green
Berets Delta guys seals uh you know
Marsa guys Force reconnaissance guys
paraforce PJs it's all it's competitive
you know and so if you're the seal that
failed the [ __ ] call shame on you you
know so you have that and then you have
the difficulty of the actual
qualification as well
and
do you yet know as you're going through
this
what's on the other side like are you
far enough into the process now where
you know hey this is Cia this is the
types of things that uh I would be going
and doing uh or is it still like
just do this we're vetting you and we'll
tell you later you know what your job's
gonna be it's very no talking and
um yeah so you don't know until you're
until you've completed it successfully
and
um looking after all my interviews that
I've done it I think that they tried to
model it maybe a little bit off of uh
what Delta what Delta guys go through
and
um
and so yeah it's very it's very
professional it's very
minimal conversation it's very direct
conversation or instruction and it's
just don't talk back just do what you're
asked to do
don't try to get a bunch of attention
you know just just show up perform
and go home yeah for uh for those who
haven't read there's a book masters of
chaos that I think really kind of
outlines the qualification course and a
lot of the uh uh Green Beret process uh
and what I think is so interesting about
that is like there's a period that's
very regimented which is uh we are going
to instruct you we are going to vet you
we are going to do all this there's
usually almost no certainty so let's go
for a run
we're running for a mile we're running
for 10. yeah let's go for a walk again
uh have this be here at this time and uh
we'll tell you then at that point what
you're gonna do
um but then there's a entire part of the
vetting process uh the Robin sage event
uh where it's very much hey this is the
objective this is the goal and it's
towards the end and so it's interesting
that that training uh is regimented with
uncertainty and then there's basically
certainty in the objective at the end
but there's not a lot of regimented uh
instruction in terms of how to
accomplish the objective and so they
almost hit both sides is that similar to
the the vetting that is at the CIA
especially in the next portion so then
you get through the shoot walls and if
you get to throw the shoe calls then you
go to basically tactics which is uh
driving then you do a lot of uh CQB
which is Clearing Houses you know and um
and that the driving doesn't really get
anybody seeking
excuse me it does start to get a lot of
people and it's tough because once again
same thing you're shooting for a job
you're being critiqued by people that
you don't know
um you don't even know if there's you
know if it's if they're subjective to
you know and and then on top of that
you're working with guys that you've not
only not worked with but that are from
different units that
do it a different way and so then in
that portion it's how does this guy
think on his feet
can he process fast by entering a room
and not be shooting innocence and and
unknowns and and killing hostages and
all that and how does he how does he
adapt how do these guys adapt working
with each other interesting who do it
completely different ways and um so that
gets a lot of guys and and that gets a
lot of egos brought out too because
everybody thinks their way is the
[ __ ] best right well
we all know there's a thousand different
ways to get a cat you know pick one and
and and go with it and and be able to
operate at the level of your you know
the guy that you're entering the room
with or your team so when you're talking
about kind of uh different units having
different styles uh the Navy Seals may
do it one way uh green braids do it
another right you kind of go down the
line
um what is that like so you're like okay
we're gonna go clear this house uh for
those that may not know some of the
details
um there may be specific tactics around
hey when we enter the door if the door
opens a certain way I go left I go right
I button hook I clear a certain way I am
able to cover people a certain way is
there a discussion before you do it or
is it more so uh kicking the door and
let's not shoot each other kick in the
door let's not shoot each other let's
not shoot any innocence and um and and
you don't know what you're walking into
so they had
here's another scenario so then you get
through that and then at the end they
really tie it all together and um one of
the drills
was they put a hood over your head
put it they give you a rifle or a pistol
you don't know if it's loaded you don't
know if if it's unloaded you don't know
if it's jammed you just have this if
they put a hood on your head then they
give you a weapon you know and you don't
know what condition the weapons in and
then there's all these role player it's
simunition rounds which is basically
kind of like high speed paintball and um
so I have all these role players in
there
and you lift the hood up and it it might
be a bunch of bat like dudes that look
bad that are coming at you but they're
not really coming at you and a lot of
guys will get amped up and they
they'll shoot you're done get out you
know you can't handle it and then the
next but you'll run through like I don't
know
three to five iterations I think is that
how quick the feedback loop is so like
literally you've got the bag on your
head you're standing there you got a gun
they pull it up and in the next 30
seconds if you do something stupid or
they've deem out of bounds literally on
the spot they say you're done get out
really yeah people get pissed
or it's not the environment they get
upset but it's not really I mean it's
just you're just I mean if you fail I
mean it's that it's it's
humiliating you know and uh and and
there's a lot of shame I didn't see
anybody get pissed I saw guys get pissed
afterwards and try to argue it you know
but in the moment like that
no and if you argue if you if you're
like no I didn't do that then you're out
yep you know there is no like I said
there's no conversation a lot of times
if you if you do something wrong you
don't even know what you did wrong you
know it's just
unsatisfactory back of the line so when
that hood comes up
what are what are kind of some of the
things that I think maybe you in
hindsight realize they're looking for is
it the ability to control your emotions
is it the ability to have uh accuracy in
shooting is it hey did he check the
weapon to even know if it's loaded or
not before anything like what are some
of the things that maybe in hindsight
are obvious that they would be looking
for
all of the above okay I think the
biggest the biggest thing that they're
doing is they're
they are dumping a tremendous amount of
stress on you and they want to see that
you could keep a level head you know and
so
they want to see when that hood comes up
you'll be able to process everything
that's happening and and and and and
perform the scenario and uh so that that
could be anything from wrestling
rescuing a hostage because as soon as
that hood comes up you're in scenario
and so that could be rescuing a hostage
that could be
there's nobody to shoot here that could
be everybody's a bad guy that could be a
fist fight one time I had the hood
pulled up the hood didn't even come all
the way up and just so I'm punched in
the face you know right right off the
bat so in the next thing you know I'm on
the ground and you know did you hold on
to your weapon when you got smacked or
did it come flying out of your hand I
mean a lot of just all those things and
so but I think the number one thing
there that gets guys is they get too
amped up they can't handle the stress
and then you got a guy who's
he runs at you and might stop and it
doesn't have a weapon and some guys will
shoot him you know and it's like
well he was running at me well did he
have a weapon
you know no we didn't well maybe it was
running because he was trying to get out
of the room because you scared the [ __ ]
out of him because you had a weapon and
you just killed an innocent you know and
and so that's
that's kind of well you're highlighting
here um it's something I think is
counterintuitive for a lot of people so
uh in the Special Operations community
in general uh there are people who are
six five 280 pounds and look what you
would expect to be a seal or or whatever
uh but I think I've read the average
height and weight it's like 5 10 180
pounds these are people who uh generally
don't look like what you would think the
Navy Seals look like in in terms of at
least the way they're portraying the
movies now I think Marcus the troll six
five so like that there's outliers for
sure
um but also uh not only in what I would
consider like the physical uh metrics
but also I think a lot of people would
expect SEALS or other special operators
to
um be bloodthirsty to be high adrenaline
to be egotistical and arrogant and uh
walk into a room and think yeah there's
15 guys in here but I'm Gonna Knock
every single one of these dudes out and
uh I'm a badass but you're highlighting
that actually they may be looking for
somebody who uh isn't six five and you
know 280 uh with muscles bulging out of
their shirt they may be looking for
somebody who actually has more emotional
control than just the the hard charger
and so did you ever kind of put it
together and understand like maybe why
they're doing that oh definitely okay
absolutely what is kind of in hindsight
what do you think is like the big
takeaways there I mean
everything that they're looking for
everything that they're looking for just
are just they don't care what you look
like they don't I mean obviously you
have to have a certain physical standard
but all they want to see that sounds
simple but it's not is guys that can
perform and analyze situations under
extremely high stress without freaking
out without curling up in a ball and
going in the corner you know they just
want to see people that can keep their
head on straight and actually think
themselves out of a situation no matter
how bad it is so once you get through
the vetting process is there then a
training process on top of uh kind of
the training you'd received as a seal or
is it pretty much you've met the
standard we know you can do this job
here's an operation go
later on uh there could be training
there's different schools you can go to
uh once you're in but that portion it's
you got the ominous dominance welcome to
CIA go to work okay you know and then
when you get in when you go to your uh
your when you go on your deployment
that's when you start getting trained by
your team it's kind of like kind of
similar to the SEAL Teams where you show
up you think you know everything you
realize you don't know [ __ ] and then the
team school should up on everything you
need to go with that being said it's
working for the agency it's complete
it's just totally different vibe than
working at the Seattle teams in what way
um I mean it's more of a you're not
going to get hazed you know it's more of
a gentleman's it would be more
professionals course yeah okay and um
then that and it's just it's a lot more
you have to be a lot more politically
correct you have to worry about people's
feelings you can't just jab somebody's
ass because they [ __ ] up you have to
actually you know go through steps and
and which is
nobody coming from Special Operations is
used to that so that's a challenge in
its own in itself but getting over there
the first thing you're gonna do
uh when you get to any location so the
training never ends is figure out where
the hell you're working so
they give you a map
mine was Cobble uh Afghanistan that was
my first deployment with him and it was
here's a map of Kabul you need to know
every road on this map starting with the
major routes then you need to know all
the back roads you need to know how to
get all these venues which hundreds of
venues and you got two weeks to learn it
and then you're operational so
you have the map they tell you you need
to do this
do you get in like a car and you drive
around and like figure it out do you sit
down uh with a big cup of coffee and
just like start reading the map like how
do you get that amount of uh detail and
information into your brain with high
information retention in such a short
period of time like what is that process
like it is it depends you know where
you're at how big the location is you
know if you're going to
a small a very small location you're not
I'll just tell you what I did so
I took the map and I just traced the
routes over and over and you got to know
the names because when you do this they
want you to be able to navigate without
a GPS without a map without they want to
be able to blindfold you and put you
somewhere and be like all right this is
where I'm at take us back home
you know without anything and um
so what I did is I took the map and I
would just Trace all the the main routes
over and over and over until I had that
image ingrained literally at the front
of my brain
and then
um while I was and then after that then
I would
have a mentor somebody would be assigned
to me and they'd be like hey take Sean
out show him a little show them the the
main routes
you know a couple times a day and
because that's your only job is to learn
so
you do that and then as more new guys
start trickling in then it's a Sean
knows a little bit about the city
Anthony just got here yesterday take
them out you guys go out it is here's
keys don't burn the vehicle meaning
don't get compromised don't have you
know don't be out there dude it's crazy
we don't want the vehicles to get burned
but you need to learn this city go drive
the city and so me and you would become
basically best friends for two weeks
that's all we're doing is just
navigating navigating every little
section of the city so then we'd start
breaking down once we know the the main
routes then we break down sections of
the city and you know every single
section then they give you a test
we started a conversation around like
The Apprentice ship model of the seals
very similar here you're talking about
essentially apprenticeship for two weeks
where hey this person knows maybe a
little bit more than I do they're going
to offload that information to me uh
when military units switch out they do
left seat right seat type stuff where
they kind of slowly work in more and
more of a unit into uh the various
convoys and operations and eventually
there's a full handoff and then the new
team is 100 of it
um does that speak just like that's the
best way to learn in your opinion is
like yeah you can sit there and look at
the map but like you got to get out on
the road you got to have somebody who
knows what they're doing and that can
drastically accelerate the learning I
think so yeah I definitely that's what
it sounds like yeah and um and I took
that model everywhere I went for the
agency so but by the end of that you
don't even you don't need a map you
don't need a GPS you can in the in the
reason they do that is is well it's for
a multitude of reasons I want you to
know what the where the hell you're
going in case something bad happens then
once you be able to adjust on the Fly
and when you're working there everything
is it's it's very precise times so if
you need to be somewhere if you need to
be on a Target if you need to meet
somebody if you need to snatch somebody
you need to be there damn near on the
second and 10 37 not 10 35 not 10 39.
exactly
and so that's why you need to know all
those back routes so that if you do get
there early then you're not driving on
the same road twice going through the
same area twice you can weave in and out
of these neighborhoods without going by
the same house twice so the people
aren't going hey what the hell is that
vehicle doing we've never seen that here
it's it passed by three times and you
don't just loiter waiting for somebody
to show up it's it's all right maybe you
get to where you're going or the area
maybe five minutes early and then you
jet in uh immediately you know on the
time stamp when you're doing this you
mentioned not burning the vehicle it's
not getting identified
um what are you wearing what kind of
vehicles are they
um and obviously share whatever you can
but like are you dressed like people
would think of uh the CIA contractor uh
that they see you know the movies is it
you've got the local kind of clothing
and trying to fit into the the culture
I'm assuming you're not in a military
uniform you know what what is that like
and is there any intentionality in what
you're wearing what vehicles you're
driving and stuff in terms of not being
uh identified yeah it's again it's kind
of all of the above it's it's
situational dependent some
some areas you go to you'll be wearing
the same thing every day some areas you
go to you're wearing a business suit in
the morning and you're wearing a
military uniform fully kidded up getting
ready to go do something by night and uh
and they're all it's just different
missions for different things and and
and so I can't get into specifics with
uh vehicles and Equipment but you could
be driving the most luxurious
the whole thing said Anne and you know
you can think of with all the little
gizmos and [ __ ] that you would think
that would be in there to a beta a beat
up does this run a piece of crap you
know something that and then you get in
and you're like whoa like
is that a rocket launch no I'm just
kidding but uh but it's it's they're all
they're souped up and then as far as
dress same thing it's you know you might
be going to have a meeting with
President Karzai one day and you're all
suited up and then the next day
you know you're you're
doing some CIA spy [ __ ] and you're
dressed up like like the locals and Arab
garms and and and however the locals
dress yeah during your time uh doing uh
the CIA work do you ever get in a
situation where they were you're like
[ __ ] they they know that I'm here oh
yeah right what whatever you could share
like how do you know that they know
um and then like what do you do right
and I think I think of that as like
probably one of the more stressful
situations you'll be put in without it
being uh full on combat and fire fights
and things like that so like how do you
kind of navigate one identifying like
[ __ ] they got me and then two like do
you leave do you just like [ __ ] it I got
a gun and if they come over here I'm
shooting or
you could but uh how do you know well uh
they'll shoot at you okay all right but
um so usually it's like that guy doesn't
belong here I'm killing them yeah some
it's not usually it's it's I've had
times where I've been walking somebody
in and
which we can go over that in a little
bit but I've had times where I'm um
um controlling an asset I'll put it that
way and then we've been compromised and
I look out my window and somebody's
their point blank shooting at me luckily
it's a up armored vehicle no you're not
going to crack the vehicle and kill that
guy because that's not what you're there
to do and if you do do that then I mean
there's other important people the
vehicle there's do you know what I'm
saying so it's not yeah you could let
your ego get to your crack seals and
kill that guy or you could just go hey
we're in an up armor vehicle [ __ ] him
let's get out of here yeah you know
before we make a bigger scene and and do
they kind of know that to some degree
like one of the things uh in my limited
experience was like there almost was
this like uh we know that if we shoot
close to them they're gonna do acts and
like as long as we can be antagonistic
uh as long as we don't kill one of them
or do anything like
the likelihood that they are going to
take the most drastic response it's not
like an airstrike's going to happen yeah
right and almost in some way they they
realize that in these situations and so
they're shooting at you and yeah if they
kill somebody they'd like that but they
don't expect you to fire back or is it
no they're like down behind a vehicle
and they're expecting a full-on fire
fight
both okay but they don't know they don't
just because they're contacting you
doesn't mean they know who you are you
know sometimes they do most of the time
they don't they're just a white dude
they just say a white boy you know
dressed up like an Arab and they're like
that doesn't that doesn't nice try you
know and uh cute Halloween costume Sean
they don't even sell those sandals
anywhere in Afghanistan
but you know but uh because I bought
them on the beach exactly but uh so it's
it's it's it could be anything it could
be a full-on assault like Benghazi you
know or I've been in safe houses that
have been compromised and had hundreds
of Fighters trying to take us out really
to you know to what I just described two
hey it might just be a mob you know
surrounding the vehicle and honestly
those are the worst because you don't
know what's coming you know it's like oh
[ __ ] am I there's women there's kids
there's bad guys there's good guys that
yeah it's complex yeah I think that's
one of the other pieces of war in
general that people forget we had a
gentleman who's on from the Intel
Community
um and he was talking about like uh in
Russia Ukraine everyone wants to say
good guy bad guy and war is just [ __ ]
complex right the good guys can do bad
things intentionally or unintentionally
the bad guys can do good things
intentionally or unintentionally and so
uh that complexity from like a macro
standpoint or a macro analysis uh okay I
think people can kind of wrap their
heads around it but what you just
describe you're sitting in a vehicle in
a foreign land where you've been
compromised and you're getting
surrounded that alone if you hadn't
passed all the vetting and have the
emotional control a lot of people who I
mean we saw it literally in 2020 there's
cops who just slam on the gas yeah right
and it's like it's a human instinct it's
not a I hate these people it's not it's
like I'm [ __ ] scared yeah and you
can't do that though because if you do
that we receive it on the news yeah
right yeah which revert back to that
training I was talking about where they
pull the hood up you're in scenario
right well now it's real you're in
scenario and yeah people do they think
it's black and white but if you're
surrounded by you know 300 people
and 10 of them are bad guys and they're
shooting at you they shoot at you you
see them and then or or they're shooting
at you then they stop they hand the they
hand their AK-47 to the pregnant woman
standing next to them now you the first
thing you see is a pregnant woman
holding an AK-47 what do you do while
you're being shot at
it's crazy you know so it really chaffs
my ass when
people are so quick to you know burn our
guys down when you were doing this this
is uh like 2010s uh 2012 2013 or what
time my last my last pump with the
agency was 2015 2015. okay so in 20 uh
2008 and nine when I was in Iraq there
was already talk of like hey if we
violate the rules of engagement hey if
we accidentally kill somebody uh that
we're not supposed to kill or all of
those types of things you're gonna end
up on the news you're gonna get arrested
like there was already this fear of the
Monday Morning Quarterback on these
situations now the positive argument
would have been it made us think more
critically about what we were doing and
so we didn't do dumb [ __ ] because there
was always this fear that it would be uh
known and uh kind of punishment for it
the downside is there's a hell of a lot
of situations
I am 100 positive dudes probably acted
slower than they should have uh
thankfully in many cases people didn't
die some of them maybe they did uh
because they were scared right is that
also true inside of the agencies as well
or is that just like more of a military
thing where it felt like uh there was
extra scrutiny during those times
I've I've never I don't think that's an
agency thing I think that's a military
thing uh I think that's yeah that's a
political type thing yeah and um you
know they were pretty good about
Shield lift in the reins and letting us
do what we need to do to keep everybody
safe and and and you know get rid of the
bad guys
um but I know exactly what you're
talking about and it was that time frame
uh
we were I was with the agency and the
Marine Corps was actually going to do
the biggest push since Fallujah and um
Hillman Province and the new Roes came
out from the Obama Administration it was
if you're shot at and the enemy drops
their rifle and you shoot you're done
you're going to jail and so yeah I think
that got a lot of people killed that
shouldn't have been killed because he
chopped the legs off of the guys out
there doing the job you know I've told a
story before uh 2008 2 30 3 o'clock in
the morning uh uh we're rolling down a
known place where our IEDs we refer to
it as ideally I think almost every Road
in Iraq at the time was probably known
as IED alley
um and uh it goes off lifts up the first
truck slams down uh
we kind of go into you know our normal
uh procedure and the truck that I'm in
we see a dude uh two guys running across
a field in the middle of the night with
[ __ ] guns he has to call for
permission to engage
and he calls and they tell him at first
no
calls again no finally by third or
fourth time they're like go ahead and so
long story short is eventually guys go
out there go down uh and they walk into
an ambush
and I remember just saying to myself
like
again
you are in a war zone an IED just went
off and there's two dudes at [ __ ]
three o'clock in the morning running
through the field with guns yeah I don't
think that they're going to the store
yeah right you know tight and so like
again it's this weird complex thing
because you understand why they're
coming up with the rules because there
have been situations that have been uh
negative they're trying to cover their
asses the fact that you're calling I
mean it's just like this crazy situation
and I'm thankful that I saw the
situation because I understand it better
but it also highlighted like there's no
way people in the media or kind of the
mainstream audience can quite understand
how complex those situations are where
so it sounds like maybe the agency was
actually a better place to operate
because you didn't have to deal with
some of that complexity and it was more
so just get your job done yeah
definitely I was in a similar situation
uh because what you're talking about in
the SEAL Teams and it was a no shoot and
that I still regret it to this day yeah
but um but yeah I didn't have to deal
with that at the agency got it uh you
mentioned earlier some pretty uh hairy
situations your safe house gets
compromised Etc is there one situation
that's like the most dangerous that you
could describe in some degree of detail
in terms of either you are like oh [ __ ]
like we're not getting out of here uh or
in hindsight it may have been really
really bad uh but you maybe didn't even
realize it at the time
couple times uh
I've been in
I gotta be careful you know how I wore
this but
yeah one time I was in a safe house and
there were not very many of us at all uh
just less than ten you know in an area
um that where where nobody nobody else
was nobody else was down there and
when you start getting into surveillance
and counter surveillance and spying on
people one of them like kind of the rule
number one is don't be time and place
predictable don't use the same routes
don't leave your house at the same time
don't go to the same spots every day
everything has to be random you don't
want to create uh what we call like a
pattern of life
um or if you do create a pattern of life
you want it to be a false one you know
you want your pattern the pattern of
life that everybody else sees
it's it's a facade you know it's you're
doing it intentionally yes because
you're using I want everybody to see me
go to Starbucks at eight o'clock in the
morning every single day everyone from
the employ you know I want everybody to
see me go to the gym right after
Starbucks you know and that would be
like a uh something here you know so you
you
kind of create your facade well we
weren't doing that at this spot and it
was
this was a remember I was talking about
at the age or at the SEAL Teams there
was this there was the guys that had
been in for 20 years who hadn't done
anything and then you have the [ __ ]
like me to come in and we'd go do it
right away well same with the agency
um similar you got all these guys that
had been you know during the Cold War
they came in they were doing all these
Cold War tactics with Russia you know
and all that stuff and then they throw
them in Iraq Afghanistan Yemen wherever
right and they're still using those
tactics
from a cold war environment
trying to get those to work in a wartime
environment where everybody wants to
kill you it's not a permissive
environment everybody wants to [ __ ]
kill you here and you'd see a lot of
these guys come and making transitions
from that kind of a career into a
wartime environment and it just it just
without any training or very minimal and
it didn't work for a long time because
it was
all they cared about was
get collecting intelligence it wasn't it
wasn't hey we need to we're going to be
here for a while let's let's not draw
them into where we live well
nobody wanted to listen and uh and I'd
mentioned I said hey we're being really
time and place predictable we've been to
this place I don't know three times in
the past week you know we need to find
different routes we need to alter our
times we need to you know meet these
people different places
didn't want to do it very next day we
got hit and uh turns out we did get
compromised we had over a hundred
Taliban fighters
uh closing in our position
and
bullets uh flying everywhere we really
couldn't engage back because we didn't
we couldn't see where everything was
coming from or it was too far uh for us
to engage and we actually oh man we that
started early in the morning and I don't
think we got pulled out until two or
three a.m at Night by the British they
had to call in British
guys to come get us uh from somewhere
else and
um but and you're just like I didn't
think we were making it out of that
you're just like sitting on your hands
like oh [ __ ] or are you guys at least
shooting what you can and and trying to
fight back
I mean we're shooting what we can but
there was there was there was a couple
of different positions they had taken
over a high-rise building that
overlooked our neighborhood and we
couldn't we couldn't see where they were
shooting from so yeah you could shoot at
the building yeah but you can't see
where the hell it's coming from and
they're throwing grenades it uh anybody
that tried to get down uh get up the
building they would just throw frags
RPGs whatever and then they had another
position where all were these Taliban
fighters were massing and uh and then it
came out it actually came out in the
news the next day that they were there
to get us
and uh
a lot of things like that happened and
so in those situations
um
you are operating with obviously what
you guys can see are you also getting
Communications like they know that this
uh these Fighters are amassing they're
able to kind of give you almost the
play-by-play I think a lot uh for those
that uh may not know as much about this
uh it's kind of like a football game the
football game's getting played but they
have coaches up in the Box who can kind
of see the the full field are you guys
getting like Intel reports and stuff
like that and you're using that to try
to fight back or is it pretty much hey
we're doing the best we can to get you
there you know get there to get you guys
but uh you're on your own right now
we were on our own it was we're probably
gonna die
let's destroy all the classified
information and uh and hope for the best
you know go down and take as many of
them with us as we can yeah pretty much
yeah and um how do you think about fight
or flight in those situations and what's
fascinating to me is uh you've pretty
much already said hey we're likely to
die here
if we try to run to the vehicles and you
know go on a high-speed chase it sounds
like you're pretty far it's not like you
can just drive down the street to a
military base where there's you know
help or anything like that uh if you
stay in fight sounds like you probably
think we're gonna get overpowered here
at some point
um is it just had a necessity you you
stay or is there a calculation between
like try to run versus stay and fight
there's just nowhere to go yeah you know
and I mean yes it could it could have
been
me and uh
two other operators that were on the
ground could have evacuated out of there
but when you have are you gonna do Third
Base when you have a a chief who's
doesn't take care of himself and he's
overweight because he's [ __ ] hot dogs
every night and you know you have you
have women who who
aren't going to do well you know leaving
you have all that ammo there you have
all the classified information there
it's it's really it's just not an option
yeah you know I I think a lot from this
story it reminds me a lot of the
Benghazi story right where basically uh
the most General description is there's
the Ambassador and kind of his living
quarters there's a safe house or a
compound that was uncompromised from
what I understand uh previously a couple
miles away and uh
there was a potential takeover of the
Ambassador and he became in danger and
so a number of operators including CIA
went to try to protect him evacuate him
Etc and then at some point they actually
evacuate back to the safe house and are
compromised and now here comes everyone
on that location in those scenarios uh
The Operators I think people have a
higher degree of confidence like
they're [ __ ] trained to survive these
situations to to excel in these
situations and probably could get
themselves individually out or the small
group but to your point there's people
who aren't trained yeah and so in movies
it is uh presented as like hey everyone
shut the [ __ ] up sit down in this room
and like we got this we're gonna go and
fight and like you guys should stay here
and and uh uh don't do anything
is that actually how it plays out or are
there scenarios where uh no it's like
dude we're all gonna die here's a gun
this is how you pull the trigger and
like get up here with us and you're
asking somebody who maybe doesn't have
the right training or as much training
to you know fight side by side with you
you get after you've been in you know a
few of these situations and you see
what a basic civilian mindset because
that is what you know CI is basically a
lot of it's a lot of college grads who
are really smart you know not the best
warfars but very intelligent College
grads they did put intelligence in the
name
right so hopefully yes yeah and uh but
you get really good at assessing
what maybe somebody can handle and so it
might not be hey here's a gun it might
be hey just
let me know if anybody if you see
anybody coming at us through that window
or let me or watch that door let me know
if anybody comes through that door
here's a radio I want you to tell this
person everything that you're seeing
right now you know and so a lot of times
uh what I would do in those situations
is that you give somebody a job and it
might not be and it'll calm them down
because then their mind's on something
other than holy [ __ ] all these bad guys
are coming to get us and so and that
particular instance it was I mean
because there's still you know even
though he's a fat slob and he can't move
he's still a [ __ ] American you know
and you can't abandon Americans and been
successful enough to achieve exactly a
station Chief or whatever so like he's
not a complete [ __ ] exactly and so so
you give them a job and a lot of in that
particular uh scenario was hey watch
Communications let us know what's coming
through you know on comms and uh with
the others it was
get all this classified stuff and and
and get rid of it you know and and so
they're busy doing that and when you do
that also it doesn't even if it's just a
[ __ ] job you know like hey go uh
make sure the [ __ ] dogs are okay you
know they're not seeing everything
develop they're not seeing the
battlefield develop no matter if you
know if it's for the better or for the
worse and so it keeps them a little bit
calmer when
when they can't see the big picture and
their minds busy doing other things is
there a flip of leadership in those
moments like prior to engagement or
combat is it like kind of like the smart
people are in charge and like we're here
to either protect them execute you know
orders whatever and like now bullets are
flying shut up sit down I'm in control
now and The Operators take over or is
there more of a balance in like the more
peaceful times oh um a lot of times it's
welcomed it's not shut up you know we're
in charge now it's they're like hey this
is why you're here
[Laughter]
and it's like I got it you know and uh
that's that's how it plays out a lot
when that's not happening yes there's
definitely a lot of animosity especially
when it comes to the guys who are doing
the cold work because they're not used
to having to work with people like us
because they're not used to working in
dangerous environments so when when they
have to get attached to people like us
uh that he goes get involved and it
turns into you know it could turn into a
[ __ ] show yeah
when you look back across military and
CIA what are like some of the core
things that you've been able to take
away as you've gone into the business
world and and the podcast and that type
of stuff like there's probably like the
easy stuff of just like hey work hard
right like how to discipline that type
of stuff but are there maybe one or two
lessons that you learned that you're
like I actually use this much more often
than people may realize that uh have
really helped you kind of in your post
military or contractor career patients
patience is a big one and um back to
that bigger picture you know being able
to step back and let a situation develop
and and look at a bigger picture
uh has has really helped me with my
business being able to not just look
right here but hey let's let's look at
all the peripherals and and and forward
thinking and planning as well I
there's a lot of Forward Thinking and a
lot of planning that goes into you know
not just operations but entire
deployments uh you know
if you're in a specific uh area of
operation the the the plan might it
might be a Five-Year Plan you know and
so
in in those planning phases and
everything I learned you know hey let's
it I brought it to business let's do a
lot more Forward Thinking and and and
and I'm not talking projections I'm just
talking you know if I do this what's
what's going to happen yeah yeah
um
do you think it helped going from the
seals you said you mentioned that you
then went and started doing some real
estate stuff but patience wasn't a key
uh a trait of yours right some of the
other things that that maybe uh you
found challenging uh coming out of the
military right into the civilian world
did you feel like the CIA was somewhat
of a step you know okay I'm not in the
military I'm not a civilian there's
still danger there's still you know
levels of combat obviously
um but it helped almost like off-board
you a little bit into the civilian world
or did it actually go the opposite
direction and like you felt like it
actually compounded some of those
problems you had to do more work once
you got out of Contracting to get back
into the civilian world
I would say the CIA definitely was a
it was a good if you paid attention
there's a lot of lessons you you could
have learned that helped you in the
civilian world and a lot more than in
the SEAL Teams uh from my experience
especially when it comes to patients
and dealing with people and and and what
is and is not socially acceptable
um with the SEAL Teams it's
I mean it's a
it's a frat house it's not a frat house
that's a that's a horrible description
but you're with a bunch of you're with
16 guys that you live
he'd sleep [ __ ] with you know for
your entire career yeah and so that
builds a camaraderie and there's a lot
of trust and and you know I think you
know where I'm going you know when when
I think of the military uh in general
I'm assuming Special Operations this
just this on steroids
um I always think of it as a high trust
environment yes right and it's like
whether that's the training whether it's
the fact that we all got Uniforms on
whether it's the flag whatever the the
reason is that can be dissected but that
high trust environment allows you to be
super honest with people
people sure get offended sometimes but
like not as much uh and there's this
element of like you do your [ __ ] job
I'll do my job and like together as a
team will be successful whereas I think
that uh
in large corporations for sure that
doesn't exist even in smaller teams
Society in general because there's not
that high trust environment you get a
lot more of the political correctness
you get a lot more of the uh you
offended me right and these things that
just they don't really exist in the
military for the most part
um sure there are the outlier situations
but uh it allows for a level of
efficiency on an interpersonal level
that just I don't see replicated very
often and I think people who are
listening or watching this
um if you have a friend who you can be
like dead on honest with like I really
appreciate that person yes and like that
person will call me you're [ __ ] up
right now right uh but that's like I'm
assuming and still team is like 15 other
guys who are all willing to do that and
if you're [ __ ] up and you're not
listening might come over there and
smack you upside the head and say hey I
told you you weren't listening a lot of
things that happen within a sales team
are inappropriate in other environments
and
um it would probably be very similar to
a Firehouse got it and um that [ __ ] does
not fly at the agency and that took me a
long time to kind of wrap my head around
I didn't like it for a long time but the
agency does have a a certain
sophistication to it that it definitely
carries over you just you learn how to
carry yourself and deal with people on a
more sophisticated and professional
manner because you have to
is is is uh as you would in the in the
SEAL Teams got it
um when you came out of the CIA uh I've
heard you talk about these psychedelics
and um it seems like that really had a
profound positive impact on kind of uh
your ability uh across a number of
different parts of your life talk a
little bit about that what were you just
like on the internet one day and we're
like I'm gonna go try this did no friend
who tried it and suggested it a doctor
like what was kind of your introduction
to psychedelics and then what was that
experience like well the no I wasn't I
didn't read it on the internet I was
actually totally against them uh
um I didn't like anything that I
associated with hippies okay and uh
communism there were psychedelics yeah
and um
and and so I I didn't even it wasn't
even on my radar to be honest with it
but
then I did this interview with uh this
uh former seal Eddie Gallagher and he
had talked about psychedelics in his
interview and and so I asked him about
it and then he connected me with
um other people who who who started a
non-profit for psychedelic therapy so I
interviewed them and I learned about a
lot about it then I started then it just
kept happening I started seeing former
colleagues of mine coming on to my show
to interview them and it was just I did
the Psychedelic therapy and my family
Dynamic changed my business changed my
anxiety's gone a lot of that stuff and
so I did it
I interviewed so many guys uh that had
gone down and and and and and done the
therapy that I was like all right I'm
gonna
you know I still have my own demons that
I need to deal with I did three and a
half years of therapy talk therapy twice
a week
and uh which did help me I would
definitely recommend it but
but um but then I moved from
uh South Florida to Nashville and that
therapy ended uh because I didn't want
to build the trust with a new therapist
things started getting out of whack uh
my business really was expanding my mind
wasn't present anymore
um I just had a son I wanted to be
present my anxiety was turning into
anger uh again and just a lot of the
stuff that guys deal with coming you
know home from combat and so things
started getting really out of whack and
I made a call and I said hey I would
like to try this you know I've heard a
lot of good things and they got me right
in
I went down there
um to do it and I did this I did
ibogaine and uh five Mao DMT
and where do you go and like what is
what is the actual process when you say
you did uh these two specific ones like
is it something that you are ingesting
are you drinking it is it a solid like
just kind of walk people through because
I think a lot of people have heard of
psychedelics but they probably don't
actually understand what that process
looks like okay ibogain comes from the
plant of Bogota which is a root in I
think it's Gabon Africa it could be off
on that but um and so what what I took
was ibigame which is
um I've been told is the most powerful
psychedelic uh on the planet and in
so it was a pill I think I took four
pills and um
and that was like a 12 hour experience
but it's very it's not like
from my experience it wasn't going out
into the end to the Jungle with a with a
medicine man and and taking psychedelics
which I would totally do now
um but this was a very controlled
Medical
type environment it was in kind of a
luxurious beach house okay
um out of the country and
but before I went down it was what are
your intentions why do you want to do
this this isn't just hey let's take
psychedelics get naked and howl at the
moon it's it's why do you want to do
this what what do you want to change
about yourself and and and talking to
therapists before you go and
so I wrote down all these intentions uh
that I wanted and then I got down there
and it was it was EKGs it was physicals
you know what medications are you on
we're going to hook you up to a heart
rate monitor and when you do it all this
all this
stuff to make it safe and um
so I did that
and when I came out I had lost 11 11
pounds uh in 12 hours 11 pounds in a
week I didn't weigh myself the whole
time but a week and I ate the food down
there is amazing and um
you're eating like four meals a day
um
great chef whatever I shouldn't have
lost weight is the point I'm making lost
11 pounds of detox 11 pounds of heavy
metals out of my system uh my eye color
changed the whites of my eyes changed
um my anxiety was gone
my I haven't had a drink in I think nine
months now I didn't even go down there
to quit drinking and uh and it wasn't
it's not it's not uh it's not hard for
me you know it's it just I just didn't
want it I it's it's almost like it
showed me this shit's poison quit
putting it in your [ __ ] body because
you're killing yourself and so sugars
went away caffeine went away alcohol
went away marijuana went away
um and I didn't go down there for any of
that the main reason I went down there
was just to be in the moment with my
with my newborn son and my wife which
happened and then all this other stuff
all these other benefits came the other
thing that happened was I quit I quit
putting that pressure on myself of what
does everybody think what you know which
really
now I realize I've really hindered my
business it was oh I don't want to do
that because I might offend somebody in
the I think I think they want to hear
this and I can't do that and it was like
[ __ ] it I don't care you know if I get
canceled I get [ __ ] canceled and they
don't like if my audience doesn't like
the content that I'm putting out then
I'll find a new audience that will and
and so it kind of gave me like
I wouldn't say courage because I've
always had courage it just gave me this
I don't [ __ ] care I'm gonna do what I
want to do finally and
and when I came home and and then you
add in you know the no drinking you
don't have that morning fog anymore and
and man it was like my business was
always on an upward trajectory and then
after that it went
straight up yeah
um why did you lose the weight is it
like uh Ayahuasca I've had people come
on and describe it as like I'm throwing
up I'm [ __ ] I'm you know like
literally purging my body the entire
time is it a similar type experience or
was it something else well it's a heavy
metal detox so you know just think of
all the heavy metals the burn pits the
ammo the bombs the everything that that
you've ingested when you were in Iraq
you know and and I don't know how long
you're over there but see that [ __ ]
stays in there you know and so when that
stuff gets sucked out of you
you know by the ibogaine that's that's
a lot of weight yeah did you feel
stronger when you came back
like did you feel if you lost weight how
did you feel physically uh it seems like
you're mentally were much clearer kind
of all these benefits what about
physically
it's it's not uh like are you asking if
I'm better in the gym or if I just felt
healthier overall both yeah I felt a lot
healthier overall yeah it's like it was
like it almost felt like a true detox
that I think people aspire to have when
they do whether it's fad diets or
whatever that's what really what they're
looking for so I want to be healthier I
want to look better or whatever as well
yes yeah
um you mentioned a second psychedelic
that you took as well uh you did those
together in the same week yes you ended
with this stuff called five Meo DMT
which is a toad denim okay and Toad
Venom sounds way cooler than the
scientific
but uh it's it's they call it a they
call it the Bliss drug
um it's an ego death you
this sounds weird have you ever done any
psychedelics I've never done any of them
and uh it's something that I find
fascinating I've Got Friends who've
built a number of psychedelic companies
and he's been talking about it forever
and so uh I actually think there's like
two or three people who I've heard talk
about it you're one of them uh in that
we have similar types of backgrounds
probably similar interests things like
that uh you're very different than I
think most people who talk about it
right uh and so I'm interested uh in
understanding more
so five five Meo DMT gives you it's it's
you die it's a death experience okay and
I know that uh I know how hard that is
to wrap your head around but
those who've done it uh definitely
understand but you you there is no doubt
in my mind
that if I die a peaceful death this is
exactly what I'm going to experience
okay explain more in terms of when you
say you died like mentally there's like
anguish and you're like this [ __ ]
sucks is it like a physical thing
it's the most profound experience of my
entire life and um and I don't I don't
say that lightly yeah
um but I'll just go through the
experience so you smoke this and um
you smoke this and they say count
backwards from 10 I hit about seven and
it was lights out but you're just
sitting there you fall back into the you
know the pillow or whatever I wanted to
do it outside because I am with no
blindfold usually they do a blindfolded
inside but I wanted to be in nature
because I'd always heard you know hey
psychedelics makes you feel like
you're in it you're in nature and um
so I did it the first thing I felt was
I felt more anxiety and fear
all at once than I have
ever felt in any other experience of my
life to include
thinking I'm gonna die in a safe house
because we're getting overrun by bad
guys
um to include
somebody's shooting at me point blank to
include all the [ __ ] I saw on the teams
and um
this was more fear and more anxiety than
I'd ever felt and it literally it really
it literally felt like
like just all this bad negative [ __ ] was
getting sucked out of my veins and um
and
that probably lasted for about 30 to 45
seconds
and I just
I just kept telling myself just let it
let just let go I think a lot of there
are guys that have bad experiences with
the stuff because I don't think they
have
I don't say this in a bad way but I
don't think they have the courage
to let go because it is the it's the
feeling that you're dying like if
there's no doubt in your head that you
you're dying and you know I've I've got
a family so that was the only thing left
that I was holding on to is I was like
[ __ ] my [ __ ] son needs me my wife
needs me to help raise my son
but then it was I was like I have to die
I have to I have to do this and
and I I Let Go
and man like the next thing you feel is
just like
pure Bliss and
and you realize every
everything that's happened to you good
bad
everything in between it was it's all
all had a purpose it was all everything
happened just the way it's supposed to
happen
and when it came to my wife and son
leaving them uh and and and and kind of
succumbing to this death
I realize that's okay too you know I was
like
they're it's okay because they're gonna
wind up here and this is
it's it's
Freedom it is Pure Freedom there's no
ego all your insecurities
are gone
you know like
none of that [ __ ] matters
um
and so I sat up and I opened my eyes
and you know uh you hear people talk
about oh the the energy and and bad
energy and good energy and I always
looked at these people like
you're [ __ ] crazy
and I opened my eyes and I saw
I didn't see anything that wasn't there
a lot of people have uh where the
blindfold they have
um hallucinations yes they have
hallucinations I didn't have any
hallucinations mine was more intuitive
and what I felt and what I saw was just
the transfer of energy through
everything through the sky through the
birds the trees the grass the ocean the
islands
off the ocean everything you can feel it
you know transferring from the grass
into your feed and when you hear people
say you know everything is one that
that's the
that's the first time that I ever felt
and knew I was like holy [ __ ] we're all
[ __ ] one thing here
this is
so if I you know
reach over the table and and try to
fight you I'm just fighting myself it's
really it's really hard to describe this
is why I'm so interested in somebody
like you who's gonna done this because I
have the same reaction right like um
my wife's got a couple friends to talk
about crystals if I hear about [ __ ]
crystals one more time I'm like shut up
right this [ __ ] is the whole [ __ ]
yeah uh uh energy like all everyone's
heard all this stuff right I'm like okay
sure guys whatever
um other than maybe like memes and Vibes
on the internet maybe I'm a little bit
of a Believer there but other than that
uh and then I I hear you talk about this
and it's like
look you're you're uh I'll call you a
normal dude right in terms of like it's
not like you were into a bunch of like
woo-woo stuff up until this point and
then the way you describe it you're like
yo it changed my life right and I think
that it's almost the contrast before and
after that's so fascinating to me you
know and
it sounds like when you came back a
bunch of good stuff started to happen
did you change anything when you came
back yeah like like action-wise okay so
you mentioned things you took away right
in terms of alcohol and caffeine things
like that what else do you notice that
you changed
ah man I just I quit listening to all
the [ __ ] you know I quit I quit
listening to what I thought
social media wanted me to do with my
business
I quit uh guilt you know we'll deal with
a lot of guilt it's it's how do I tell
this person I don't want to do this or
how do I I just don't feel it anymore
you know and it's starting to come back
a little bit but it's it and and because
you're not focusing all your energy on
well I don't want to hurt Anthony's
feelings and and because I don't want to
fly down for his podcast so how do I
tell them this and why the [ __ ] is that
person thinking that about you know
instead of worrying about all this [ __ ]
is hey man I I can't make it down or you
know family you know I can't I can't do
it I have this I need in in it takes it
takes the guilt away and if you think
about how much time you waste on trying
not to offend somebody or trying not to
make somebody feel bad or when somebody
you have to get asked all the time could
you just could you can you do this for
me can you do that you know it you don't
feel bad saying using the word no
anymore and it's just no I'm I'm not
gonna do it I noticed that there's
momentum with the use of the word no
there's something I've been thinking
about recently
if I start to say no to people
it becomes easier like the rest of the
week or that month or whatever and then
if I become undisciplined and I say yes
once or twice next thing I'll say yes to
everything like like there is this
momentum or almost like uh maybe
confidence or I don't know how you would
describe it but it's like
if you have the ability to say starting
today I'm going to say no to people I
want to say no to it is easier yeah and
I don't know if it's like an identity
thing like I'm somebody who says no I
don't know if it's literally momentum or
whatever but it does feel like uh people
who say yes to a couple of things say
yes to everything people who say no are
very disciplined when they say no and so
it almost feels like just getting the
right directional like path of progress
is an important piece to it sounds like
this was a moment where it really sets
you on a certain path and you've just
kind of stayed on that
that's I never thought of it like that
that's a great way to put it but um yeah
you know I just I started I finally
started saying no and and because I was
you know somebody told me once it was
actually my mother-in-law said every
time you say yes to somebody you're
saying no to somebody else and so I've
always thought about that and then after
doing the psychedelics I was like [ __ ]
you know she's right and so I took all
that energy of doing
[ __ ] for people that they don't even
really give a [ __ ] if you're doing it
for them if they say if you say no
they're just on to the next person right
hey could you and so I took all that
energy and applied it to my family and
my business and myself and that's when
things really really started coming
together for me
as you've gone through your career
you've had kind of I'll call it three or
four different careers right you had uh
kind of uh the seals CIA and what you're
doing now at a minimum
um
do you still have the same friends do
you still have the same like peer group
through all of that or have you found
that either through necessity or uh
benefit that you've kind of changed over
time right and I think about this from
the perspective of like if it's an
intentional thing right so uh you go
from the sales to the CIA CIA to kind of
the business world
if you don't have the same friend group
they may be offended oh he thinks he's
too good for us oh he he uh now doesn't
have time for us or whatever do you
experience that at all oh yeah okay do
you yeah hell yeah right and and uh
I mean there's people who will listen to
this and be like he's talking about me
and there's people who listen to this
but he's definitely not talking about me
but some of them are intentional right
some of them are like hey this person is
not conducive to what I'm trying to
accomplish and like uh they're the
energy vampire or whatever you want to
describe it but like
sorry dude right usually dudes uh it's
just honestly I don't have time for this
yeah and in those cases to me I don't
feel guilty I actually like that's
easier for me to deal because I'm making
the decision
it's the people in your life that like
you're just focused on what you're doing
and so like there's not as many
intersection points or like as much time
uh that overlaps and you just kind of
grow apart
I still feel sometimes guilty to some
degree or like I'm like damn I wish it
wasn't this way and I almost have to
like yeah but that's just the way it is
yeah I don't know what about you
well I was going to ask if you figured
out how to filter it yet
I'm still working on this how I filter
it yeah how do you do it right now I
filter it
I
I try to filter it is when it comes to
friends who who can you tell your
successes to without people getting
jealous of where you're at in life and
that's what I'm really starting to
figure out is you can't you can't be
[ __ ] around with people that aren't
happy for you if they're not happy for
you the only reason they're not happy
with you is they're not happy with their
own [ __ ] performance but they're not
willing to do anything
to up their performance they're just
going to keep you down
wherever they're at and so
when I when I think of who I can tell my
successes to it's probably tell them to
you know
five people if that and so that's who I
concentrate all my energy on and
everybody else you know if we were
friends and and you're not happy for me
now that doesn't mean we're not I hate
you or I'm not gonna talk to you but I'm
not going to focus much energy on you
anymore because
I know there's always going to be that
underlined resentment you know and that
jealousy and it and that shit's toxic
you know it is toxic
I had a um I went to a dinner and it was
a dinner I should not have been at there
was four or five different billionaires
there and they were all friends and so
you're at this dinner maybe there's
eight to ten people whatever it was
um and you already feel like a little
bit of an outsider right because like
they're all friends and you're like
Jesus like some of you uh in a business
since I look up to you I want to learn
from you like all the stuff and uh the
things that they were talking about at
this dinner
I was looking around I was like you guys
sound like the most arrogant Fox I've
ever heard right
but what I realized was no like like
after I left at dinner I was like these
guys grew up together they literally had
nothing and so they used to talk about
like the first customer they got
together right and they'd come and
they'd be like oh I got my first
customer like oh that's cool like you
know whatever and it's risen and now
they're talking about do you want to buy
you know a 50 million dollar boat
together and none of them were judging
each other because it was like they had
risen up to this level of success but
they also were on the same level as well
so it wasn't like uh one of them was a
billionaire and the other you know was
unemployed and so like if the
billionaire was like I think about
buying this boat the other person's like
well [ __ ] you you know I'm trying to
find a job
and so there was like the the path
together I think kind of created some
camaraderie but also the ability to talk
to people who didn't judge them even
though they were talking about things
that everyone else in the world would be
like
that's what you're worried about you're
literally worried about like you can't
find staff for your boat right I'm just
making up whatever but to the other ones
they're like no I can't either yeah
right how are you trying to solve that
problem and so it sounds similar to kind
of what you're talking about of just
like the people who want to see you
successful the people who you feel
comfortable sharing the truth with are
actually the people who you end up kind
of spending your time with yeah no I'm
I'm
um well I don't think it always has to
be
like levels okay now I think I think it
just has to be who's happy for it or
who's happy with themselves you know I
mean because you see this that would be
like a financial or business uh scenario
but then you have family scenarios and
you know you get a lot of people who I
don't know what your family situation is
but if it's good you probably have a lot
of people who are in a shitty family
Dynamic who are jealous of what you have
with your wife and your kid you know we
see that uh me and my wife see that or
or
you know they're they're jealous of your
business they're jealous of
people get jealous of how many followers
you have on Twitter you know and and and
so
when you see that when I see any of that
come out I'm like all right we need to
pull back here and and concentrate more
on on
these people because they're happy for
us they're happy in their lives and does
that make sense it makes 100 sense and
actually When you mention things like
social media I've talked to people who
have immense millions of subscribers on
YouTube or whatever and every once in a
while they'll say something to me to the
effect of like sometimes I wish I could
go back and have none yeah right because
you mentioned earlier like what your
audience wants some of them are like hey
you know what there's one person
thinking in particular he's one of the
top 15 YouTubers in the world and he's
like when I started doing this I had
certain interests it was not the same
interest I initially have today but I
feel like I got a job now yeah and like
they've almost become the audience is
the boss yeah which is a little weird as
well right do you feel that sometimes I
did before psychedelics
now I don't talk about the business that
you have built like how do you think
about uh what it entails and like what
are you trying to accomplish right I
always think of like businesses have
some sort of mission or goal that
they're going after like what are you
driving
you know
everybody it's everybody's it's all
preparation right I want to make more
money so that my kid can go to the best
private school I can get the car I want
I could live in the good neighborhood I
don't want to be in in a neighborhood
with a bunch of crime and right it's all
money and possessions and stuff like
that and
I don't think a lot of people invest for
what's coming after this life and in in
whether that's you know whether you
believe in uh some type of religion or
whatever I just believe if you inject
good into this world then good [ __ ] is
going to come your way
and that's all I [ __ ] care about man
is I want you know I I we do heavy heavy
heavy interviews uh where I'll bring
you know a Delta guy to his most
vulnerable state that he's ever [ __ ]
been in you know mentally
and because he's there or I go there
or whoever's on the show goes there that
that lets everybody because he's the
Delta guy or because I'm a seal and a
CIA guy or because you're a you know
business phenomenon uh
you know people look at that and they're
like well [ __ ] if that guy if that guy
could admit that and and then I can do
that or if that guy can work on himself
and admit these faults then I can do
that and if he can get if he's been
through all that [ __ ]
I can get through my little mess you
know and
and I that's one aspect the other thing
I like to accomplish is I'm you know
with podcasts a lot of people all they
care about is I I need to get I need to
get the guy with a million followers on
my show because everybody's going to
want to listen to what I never listen to
that [ __ ] I always liked getting the guy
that nobody would give the [ __ ] time
of day to because he's new starting a
business you know struggling
grinding it out and I can pull him and
be like hey man I see what you're doing
and you're [ __ ] doing a good job and
and I want to give you an audience that
you probably never would have had
exposure to
and
and I'm lucky you know and I use it for
good but when people come on my show
their [ __ ] business goes through the
roof and so I'm very selective on on on
who I bring on especially when it comes
to you know the former military guys or
or the uh CIA guys but
I bring them on and the audience gets to
learn all these lessons their business
takes off they learn a lot uh you know
I'll do a lot of Consulting you know for
guys after the show
um after release I'll make sure like hey
man are you ready for this [ __ ] because
you know like I just did this guy Cody
Alford and I called Cody like the day
before
his episodes released I'm like hey what
are you doing you know how are you ready
you're gonna [ __ ] blow up and he
didn't believe me and he's like man I'll
just it's rough my best friend just died
just tell a little bit about Cody's
story because I think he's actually like
a pretty interesting uh uh maybe example
Cody yeah of the types of people that
you would bring on Cody
normal guy you know
didn't grow up in a wealthy family it
wasn't like a super athlete at anything
joined the Marine Corps
the fastest guy ever in the Marine Corps
to make E8
um was one of the was one of the first
guys uh to stand up marsac phenomenal
operator for not like the guy's just a
the badass
he's he's he just wins it every [ __ ]
thing he does and
no matter what the struggle is he
overcomes it
so
just phenomenal career phenomenal
operator
um a very just a solid human being call
him up he's he's
a little depressed his best friend had
just died obviously understandable his
business he's grinding grinding grinding
he's not getting a [ __ ] break
and he's like man I just I don't have
any shirts in stock I don't have this I
don't have that and I'm like what the f
I was like hey man this [ __ ]
opportunity is not gonna come again I
was like so here's what you're gonna do
you're gonna [ __ ] do a pre-sale on
all your [ __ ] shirts
you're gonna stand up a patreon account
you're going to get your online coaching
going and you're going to have all this
[ __ ] on your website by tomorrow
and he's like people don't like
pre-orders I was like I was like you
don't get it I was like nobody gives a
[ __ ] about your apparel they give a [ __ ]
about you and what you just told me on
that show people are going to want to
support you they don't care if you're
selling [ __ ] bath water they're going
to buy it because you shared your
darkest deepest most inner
vulnerabilities and insecurities
and they're going to take that learn
from it they want to support you and
sure should you know I talked to them a
week after and he's like man he's like I
just had the biggest month you can take
every month of last year
put it together and it wouldn't be the
month that I just had after your show
and I was like [ __ ] hey man keep it
going you know but um so to be able to
do that you know is a big responsibility
and and it's it's a gift and it's
putting good into the world because Cody
has a great message he's a solid human
he's a good person he's putting out
things that are helping people and
really all I did was just give them a
platform to tell everybody what he's
doing what he's been through and and
boom and I've done that with you know a
lot of people so
that's what I get out of it anything
else you know it's kind of icing on the
cake and and and I've always been a
believer that if if you do good and you
just
the money's gonna be there you know I I
think the money is it's just it's going
to be there and for me you know
business and money was there you know it
took a while but that's what I get out
of it what's up with the gummy bears the
gummy the gummy I think the first
um I haven't told you this yet uh I
think the first episode I ever saw was
when he did uh DJ Shipley and uh I
didn't know you were didn't know
anything about it
somehow YouTube recommended it shout out
to Susan and the YouTube team who uh you
know great great recommendation
algorithm
and uh
I clicked on it I don't freaking
remember why I don't remember what title
was whatever but like I clicked on it
and uh you have like a piece of the
interview up front I think I remember oh
[ __ ] okay this thought it was like three
hours and I'm like oh [ __ ] I got like
five minutes yeah so let me let me uh
save this one I remember uh that night I
sat down to go watch it and uh my wife
was coming in and out of the room
and about 20 minutes he goes what the
[ __ ] are you watching
sit here look at these two dudes talk
whatever and but I was hooked right now
I was just like okay like this is gonna
be a great conversation as it went
further and further I was like oh this
is uh two guys who have very unique
experiences in the world but there's
that high trust environment they're
going to talk about things in a way that
just isn't going to be done elsewhere
and then I don't know a couple minutes
into the interview or whatever all
sudden it's a [ __ ] ad and oh yeah
okay cool ad then I realized it was ads
for your gummy bears and I was like what
a [ __ ] guy he's got all these badass
guys coming in having these great
conversations but he's selling gummy
bears if I ever talk to him I'm gonna
ask him what is up with the gummy bears
so where did the gummy bears come from
what why did you say hey we should go
actually have a product with Gummy Bears
what what is this so it kind of started
so before I did the Sean Ryan Show I was
teaching tactics how to clear rooms
shooting tactics [ __ ] like that
and
every time I enter space I like to
research what what is happening in the
space
so
I started training started building
social media and I was looking at what
everybody else is doing what are
excuse me
what are all my peers doing well they're
all acting like hard asses they don't
eat anything but protein shakes and
chicken breasts they never have any fun
they're always serious you know they
look like an [ __ ] so I was like all
right I'm going to do the exact [ __ ]
Opera I was like I was like I'm a seal
CIA guy so people are already scared
shitless of you just knowing that about
you so we have to disarm them if they
actually want to learn anything and so
and and make yourself approachable and
and allow people to realize oh this
guy's just a [ __ ] human and so
how I did that is I started when
everybody else was posting their their
Milkshakes that they're taking in the
morning and their testosterone shots and
their chicken breasts I was like I like
[ __ ] donuts and Milk Duds and gummy
bears and ice cream and I'm a human I
like
I like candy sugar tastes good and uh
and people like that you know and so and
I
so that's kind of how it started and
then you know I was just looking people
like oh well you have to have apparel
you have to have products to sell and so
it's like all right well I have sleep
problems let's do CBD gummies and we'll
we'll make a CBD gummy line and
and uh whatever and my marketer was like
don't do that you're gonna get sued for
marketing to kids
so I said all right fine we'll just do
regular gummy bears and um
so I was like all right let's just order
a
let's find them make them and
Market them and see what happens and
I just took off and uh just
just regular gummy bears and so so it
just stuck you know and then we ordered
more and they sold out and then we
ordered more and they sold out so now
it's
it's just like this staple of my
business yeah and uh you obviously do a
great job kind of integrating into the
show when you get the ads and all that
stuff
um is it something that you want to take
and put into stores and kind of grow you
know as if you were a candy company I
guess or uh is it something that just
like no we want to keep doing the
content and have the conversations and
that and this is just you know a thing
that is part of what we do uh but it's
not really going to be a massive Focus I
would love to get something in stores
but I don't I don't think that's the I
don't think that's the product because
nobody's gonna go to Walmart and buy a
10 a 10 bag of Gummy Bears when they can
get three times the size of a different
kind of gummy bears for three bucks so
it's you know it's a novelty item and
it's a way for for people to like what
I'm doing to to support me and so I'll
probably just keep that online you know
and as you think about uh the content
itself one of the things I noticed is uh
it's very high quality right um it seems
like you've been one very thoughtful but
to really focus on the quality
um you've got the interviews uh do you
have aspirations and kind of uh plans to
do things outside of just the interviews
or like how do you think about like
other pieces of content
I started I started doing a lot of
I spent a lot of time dabbling in
different projects and and so everything
from going up to Alaska and doing like a
quasi Survival series to going down to
Tijuana and doing a whole cartel like
kind of kind of cartel border southern
Mexico or northern Mexico kind of uh
newsy type content that most people
won't do because they're too scared to
go get in those neighborhoods and do it
but
where I'm going is is
after the psychedelics I decided it
would be best to just concentrate on one
thing and make that one thing really
really really good and so that's what
I've done and and I think I will just I
will continue to build this show up and
and instead of doing all these different
types of content
getting more diverse guests is kind of
where I'm headed yeah
um I really enjoy the conversations uh
and I always think about
um conversations are only as good as the
questions they ask what's the research
process like that that you kind of go
through and then how do you determine
what are the questions you'll ask versus
the things you're like yeah I could ask
but not really something that either
you're interested in or you think will
be valuable for the audience
I used to do I used to do a ton of
research I think the DJ Shipley one you
had like a whole notebook full of
questions it seemed yeah I did and um I
used to do a ton of research
and then I kind of just got into a
Groove and I got better to talk in it
talking with people and so sometimes
I'll just go in there
with
no plan at all and a lot of times those
wind up being the best ones but um
you know and now I can do that with the
operator type guests is I kind of know I
have a flow I know a little bit about
them you know and it's easy to research
because I can ask around about them but
I I really hindered my business with
research uh early on it was I put so
much [ __ ] pressure on myself to know
everything about
the guest that's coming on I try to read
every book they wrote I'd try to
you know do their online training
programs and it it hindered my business
like I was condensed it and then if I
can I just [ __ ] can it to be honest with
you and
and what I go off of now is I just got
really good at reading the guest I know
what they're willing to do I know what
they're not willing to do and and I
always push the limits with the
questions you know I ask the questions
that that
people don't want to ask and um
like here's an example I just
interviewed this hasn't come out yet but
I just interviewed this guy
um
who in his childhood he had a Peeping
Tom for four years in his windows
parents didn't believe it then his dad
became abusive and uh and um and I could
and he had been through a ton of [ __ ] in
the military
um Marsa guy
and he started standing up he started he
didn't want to get into the abuse uh
from his from his father
and so
normally people would just go okay well
he doesn't want to talk about it let's
go on we didn't want to talk about it so
I said hey
it doesn't appear to me that
you don't want to talk about this
because of what happened to you it
appears to me that you don't want to
talk about this because you want to
stand up for your [ __ ] abuser and I
was like all you're doing on this show
is telling the audience
what you experienced and and your
interpretation of that experience so my
question is why the [ __ ] are you
standing up for the abuser and
questions like that you know will it
will just it'll blow the interviewee out
of the [ __ ] water they're just like
[ __ ] you know called me out yeah and and
it turned into a really really good
conversation but
um finding those kind of rabbit holes to
go down I've found is is
and there wouldn't I wouldn't have found
out that he was you know abused as a
child had
and gone down that rabbit hole because
it wasn't anywhere you know and so
that's another thing with mine people
they get in that interview room and
they've seen a lot of the other episodes
and they kind of know what they're in
for now so they're willing to go
deeper you only agree to show up if
you're gonna have a conversation yeah I
enjoyed talking to other people who do a
lot of interviewing because uh I find
the conversations are uh much more
meaningful right and
um I think I've come to the conclusions
because they know how to ask questions
and they also uh know that if you're
gonna ask the questions you got to be
willing to answer questions yeah right
and it's like I've got a couple friends
who will ask me stuff and I yeah
whatever like no no no hold on if you're
gonna ask other people questions you got
to answer them yeah okay fair uh so you
got to be careful people don't weaponize
it against you right
um the last thing I want to talk about
is just like you've built this
incredible audience what have been some
of the coolest moments for you like most
people would look at your life and be
like wow it's amazing to be a Navy SEAL
it's amazing to work for the CI it's
amazing to do all this stuff but my
guess is that you actually have like
some pretty cool things that now you're
like I cannot believe this or that
because the audience is made up of such
diverse people uh it's gotten so large
like what are are some of the cool
moments that you've experienced there
where you're just kind of like I gotta
pinch myself because I can't believe
this is real for somebody who's been
through kind of what I've been through
man there's a lot I will say I don't
dwell on success much do you no
I don't have time for it it's my uh
maybe my biggest downfall or like
challenge but uh I also am not probably
as good as I should be in terms of uh
giving people uh positive feedback
like a kind of more focus on the
negative feedback of like like the
positive shoot is the expectation yeah
uh which I think
I like that too yeah I think it's kind
of a uh if you're into the military or
that whole world it's not a lot of guys
walking around being like good job
there's a lot of people like you're
[ __ ] up
and so I've tried to get better at it uh
but um yeah the successes are just kind
of yeah just like what's next yeah I'm
like that too uh some of the things that
stick out I guess the Eric Prince
interview is
awesome yeah you know to just to to have
somebody like that sitting in front of
you with the circles that that guy runs
in it's like holy [ __ ] and the knowledge
that he's I mean
I don't think half of America can even
comprehend what was coming out of his
mouth no and uh just I told you this
beforehand but it's important to me that
I say it on here that interview
specifically I think is in the last for
sure year maybe a couple of years it's
probably my most shared interview in the
sense of like after I listened to it I
send it to a bunch of people half of
them were like pop you're crazy like
stop sending me this [ __ ] right it's
just like who the [ __ ] is Eric Prince
and the other half people were like what
yeah and uh uh the first half is
interesting if you understand Blackwater
and a lot of the controversy and things
they went through the second half was
kind of like the world is [ __ ] right
it was kind of like one of the takeaways
um and so highly suggest people listen
to it but uh that one for you felt like
that was a kind of a trophy that you
were able to uh to have that
conversation yeah and then another one
would be the the what led to that
interview was the Blackwater guys and uh
this is
that's probably my favorite one
um
there was back in 2007 I don't know if
you remember there was a big shootout in
nissour square in Baghdad uh
Obama Biden Administration railroad of
those gents uh three of them were in for
30 years one was in for life they
deleted the evidence they deleted the
Drone footage that whatever they got
railroaded if you want to know the ins
and outs there's an interview out there
I'm the only one to ever get those four
guys in the same room to tell their side
of what happened that day and uh with
the the liberal news reporter who
actually
brought this to Trump which led to their
pardons uh that was
and to see like
see those guys
get to open up about that day because
they've the media never gave them the
[ __ ] opportunity to tell their side
it was just railroad these Obama once
these guys railroaded [ __ ] railroad
them they never gave them the time of
day so to see like
the peace come over them after that
interview like
we got our
we got to tell the world you know what
what really happened that day our side
of it and well their side
was not helpful for the public narrative
no right and I think that we're seeing
that uh across the mainstream media over
and over and over again uh social media
changed that shows like yours have
changed that where uh now people have a
voice
it does make you think damn how many you
know stories of History
if we got the other side yeah again not
necessarily meaning that the other side
is 100 accurate either but like maybe we
would just kind of be in the middle and
say like oh this is more complex than
either side wants us to understand
exactly
um but yeah it is fascinating just to
realize like these guys went all the way
including jail
and then got to tell this story yeah
tried three times they tried them three
times and uh they they just weren't
gonna stop until they got a guilty
verdict and and um
but are they mad those guys man you know
I think they're at peace yeah you know I
think
sitting in prison for seven years I
think it was you know that
it I think it gave them it's something
that you know I can't ever comprehend
but I think that just gave them a new
appreciation uh
you know for for being free you know and
and
they're just really appreciative of it
you know one guy Nick slad and he won't
I don't think that guy will ever leave
his town again uh he lives in a small
town in Tennessee but you know Paul he's
one of them he's out public speaking now
which is just I mean did from what they
have been through to be able to come out
in the public and
let's just phenomenal you know and uh so
so the biggest ones for me you know
it's it's watching the success that I
can help bring
other people you know is is the real
that's what makes me feel the best you
know there's yeah the business wins and
stuff like that that's always cool but
um you know I think we're very similar
it's we don't celebrate the successes
who the hell are you going to celebrate
them with anyways right
that's a great way to look at it uh
where can we send people to find you on
the internet or find more of the show uh
just Sean Ryan Show Sean ryanshow.com
Sean Ryan shows all the
social media handles and then my
personal stuff Sean ryan762. awesome
well listen I really appreciate you
coming and doing this uh I've learned a
lot from the show and I really enjoyed
talking to Dan we'll definitely do it
again in the future thank you thank you
for having me I really appreciate it